Wisst ihr,
was Nerds wirklich aufregt?
*Musik*
Nein.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Wisst ihr, es gibt so Sprüche,
da fehlt mir als Wissenschaftler
einfach der Humor:
"Alkohol ist keine Lösung,
sondern ein Destillat".
Oder auch: "Nach den physikalischen
Gesetzen kann die Hummel
gar nicht fliegen.
Aber davon weiß sie nichts
und tut es einfach".
Nichts gegen motivierende Sprüche -
aber nicht auf Kosten der Physik.
Ja, ich weiß,
was der Spruch bedeuten soll:
Du sollst an dich glauben
und es gibt so viele Menschen,
die das vermeintlich Unmögliche
möglich gemacht haben.
Und gerade in den Naturwissenschaften
sind natürlich die Entdeckungen,
die größten, die den Status Quo
der naturwissenschaftlichen Gesetze
infrage
oder auf den Kopf gestellt haben.
Aber physikalische Gesetze
sind keine Straßenverkehrsgesetze,
die man einfach brechen kann.
Denn in dem Moment wo man sie bricht,
müsste man sie neu definieren.
Wenn normale Gesetze
so wie physikalische Gesetze wären,
dann wäre das so:
"Junge Frau, Sie können nicht
bei Rot über die Straße gehen".
"Doch, das kann ich sehr wohl, haben
Sie es etwa gerade nicht gesehen"?
"Dann müssen wir wohl
das Gesetz ändern".
Z.B. die Gravitationstheorie
nach Newton ist ausreichend
für fast alles, was wir
hier auf der Erde beobachten.
Aber dann kam irgendwann Einstein
und er verband Raum und Zeit.
Und er sagte: "Eine Masse
krümmt die Raumzeit", usw.
Und man musste
die Gravitation neu definieren.
Wer sich für das Thema interessiert,
kann sich ein altes Video
von mir anschauen.
Aber darum geht es
jetzt auch gar nicht.
Was ich damit sagen will, ist,
wenn ich diesen Apfel hier
loslassen würde und er würde nicht
nach unten fallen, sondern nach oben,
dann müsste man die Gravitation
aber "Fucking Hallo"
noch mal neu definieren.
Und wenn Hummeln die Gesetze
der Aerodynamik brechen würden,
dann müsste man diese
schleunigst auch neu definieren.
Deswegen macht dieser Hummelspruch
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Und ja, ich sage gerne "Sinn machen"
statt "Sinn ergeben",
weil ich finde, dass Umgangssprache
auch eine Sprache ist,
und dass sich Sprache
weiter entwickelt.
Und wenn du ein Deutsch-Nerd bist,
den das zu sehr aufregt,
dann musst du
dein eigenes Video machen.
Aber das hier ist mein Nerd-Rent.
Wo war ich?
Jedenfalls, physikalische Gesetze
sind keine unverbindliche Empfehlung,
der man nachkommen kann
oder auch nicht.
Sie beschreiben die Realität.
Und fliegende Hummeln
gehören nun mal zur Realität.
Okay, kommen wir doch mal
zu den physikalischen Gesetzen,
die hier so schändlich
zitiert werden.
Der ganze Mythos, dass Hummeln
eigentlich gar nicht fliegen können,
geht auf den
französischen Insektenforscher
Antoine Magnan zurück, bzw.
auf sein Buch "Der Flug der Insekten"
aus dem Jahre 1934.
Dort rechnete er aus,
dass ein Flugzeug mit Hummelgewicht
und einer Flugzeugtragfläche
in Größe eines Hummelflügels
nicht fliegen könnte.
Das stimmt so erstmal.
Und jetzt: finde den Fehler!
*Musik*
Genau.
Hummeln sind keine Flugzeuge.
Z.B. bewegen Hummeln ihre Flügel
und das nicht zu wenig.
Bis zu 200 mal pro Sekunde.
Daher kommt auch das Geräusch.
Hier gibt es nicht nichts zu fassen.
Dabei können die ziemlich versierten
Pummelflieger nicht nur Schlaufen
und Achter schlagen, sondern sie
können ihre Flügel auch drehen,
d.h. Ober- und Unterseite wechseln,
was sie auch mit jedem Schlag machen.
Dabei entstehen kleine
Luftwirbelströme, die so verlaufen,
dass ein
zusätzlicher Auftrieb entsteht.
Ansonsten entsteht der Auftrieb
dadurch, dass die Hummelflügel,
genauso wie Flugzeugflügel,
gekrümmt sind,
so dass die Luft oben schneller
vorbeifließt als unten.
Das nennt man den Bernoulli-Effekt.
Der lässt sich auch ganz gut
mit einem Blatt Papier beobachten.
(pustet)
Seht ihr, ich blase über das Papier.
Dadurch wird der Luftstrom
hier schneller als unter dem Papier.
Dadurch wird der Druck über dem
Papier geringer als unter dem Papier.
Und es entsteht ein Auftrieb.
Das - plus die Wirbelströme
durch den geschickten Flügelschlag -
und die Hummel
summt fröhlich durch die Luft.
So, aber am schlimmsten
sind die Motivationsgurus,
die auch noch Zahlen einbringen.
Lass bloß die Zahlen da raus!
Zahlen gehören
zu wissenschaftlichen Fakten.
Allein die beiden hier:
Hier wiegt die Hummel 4,8 g und
hat eine Flügelfläche von 1,45 cm².
Und hier wiegt die Hummel
nur 1,2 g und hat eine Flügelfläche
von nur 0,7 cm².
Erstens sind das offenbar
nicht dieselben Zahlen,
was ja noch okay ist,
da Hummeln sicherlich
verschieden groß
und verschieden schwer sind.
Aber dann soll man nicht so tun, als
wären das allgemeingültige Zahlen.
Und 2. haben wir es hier
noch nicht mal
mit dem selben "Masse-zu-
Flügelflächen-Verhältnis" zu tun.
Und auch wenn ich denke, dass
das 2. Beispiel eher der Realität
eines Hummel-Körperbaus entspricht,
will ich damit nur sagen:
Wenn du jemanden motivieren willst,
fein, aber beleidige nicht
die Physik,
in dem du Zahlen verwendest,
um Sinnlosigkeiten
zu unterstreichen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt:
"Mai, das ist doch nur ein Spruch,
warum regst du dich so auf?"
Dann, Freunde der Sonne,
seid ihr offenbar keine Nerds.
Good for you!
Schönschlau.
Freunde der Sonne,
wenn ihr Freunde der Hummeln habt,
die gerne diesen Spruch benutzen,
dann wisst ihr, was zu tun ist:
Schickt ihnen dieses Video.
Und wenn euch der Spruch
sonst irgendwo begegnet,
dann wisst ihr ab jetzt,
was ihr zu antworten habt.
Im Namen der Physik.
Ach Schätzeleins,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.